moving very quickly on the eagle-eyed
amongst you will notice that we have two
chairs next to me one of these chairs is
for Kari Flynn who is a journalist who's
written for Huffington Post Forbes Money
Magazine and is now business reporter
for Mashable with this particular
specialism in the tech industry the
other chair is for Gary Vaynerchuk who
has a formidable headline which is Gary
Vaynerchuk builds businesses and that is
something that absolutely no one can
argue straight out of college he took
his family business from 3 million to 60
million in five years he's a prolific
angel investor and venture capitalist
with investments including uber Facebook
and Birchbox he now runs vaynermedia
social media first digital agency and
has been named to both Fortune and
cranes 40 under 40 list this year
please welcome Carrie and Gary
hello hey guys thanks for that great
introduction um so yes I'm Kerri Flynn I
write from Mashable and here with Gary
so I'm guessing you guys I mean you got
a brief introduction I'm thinking you
guys probably all know Gary Vaynerchuk
but I would love Gary for you to
introduce yourself when you go to an
event how do you how do you introduce
yourself well I think you know I think
the fragmentation of attention and
marketing and comms is so intriguing I
actually think how many people here have
no idea who I am raise your hand that
was that was a good ego boost
you know usually usually how I go into
conferences is asked that question and
the number is always very very high and
I can always see like the organizer
squirming of either they overpaid me or
they feel bad for me but usually i you
know i contextualize myself as an
entrepreneur but i always reverse
engineer at the audience right like my
biggest my biggest want up here in our
next 30 minutes is I was walking around
and looking at name tags asked ahead of
time we talk like to me what I'm gonna
deliver is the context of what I think
is the most interesting and most
valuable thing to talk about to the
people in the room I think as somebody
who's been on stage a lot I'm fascinated
by how 80% of presentations are just one
long press release right so I think I
take this very seriously and and the way
I introduce myself usually is under the
context of what could conceivably bring
value to the people in the audience
great well then let's talk a little bit
about being a media in terms of building
that out is it seems to be you really
went with that mission in mind what did
you really want to offer the world that
didn't hunt that didn't exist before so
I grew up in my family's liquor store
business and I watched one of the first
e-commerce wine businesses in 1996 and I
built my business with no money and the
reason it became a big business was
because I bought Google AdWords the day
came out for five cents a click for the
word wine and because I started a
YouTube show five months after YouTube
came out
and because I had an email newsletter in
1997 that had 91% open rates big and so
my entire narrative has been very simple
and I think for all of us in this room I
think the world is pretty basic mainly
because I'm pretty basic which is
there's overpriced attention and there's
underpriced attention and while most of
the world that spends a lot of time
trying to quantify and find the ROI of
underpriced attention I think the better
model is to be a practitioner on your
intuition around normal people's
behavior learn it and maximize the ROI
so I did that for my family business
that went great
then I invested in all these companies
Facebook Twitter Tumblr made a lot of
money and then I decided in my continued
mission to buy the New York Jets though
they're testing me that the way I was
gonna do that was to buy brands and flip
them so I think nostalgia is the most
underpriced asset in the world and so my
dream is to buy tootsie rolls or k-swiss
sneakers or what have you at scale 50 60
100 200 million dollars do the thing
that I do and then flip it for 1 billion
dollars and that's how I think I from a
self-aware standpoint can achieve my
audacious goal to do that I knew I knew
that I needed to understand marketing
and media at the scale of which I wasn't
playing at as an entrepreneur and as the
Bester
so I decided seven years ago to eat [ __ ]
for a decade and build a client service
business and and
and and I needed to learn why all these
big brands were doing the things that I
thought were stupid because I didn't
have the audacity or the ego to think
they were stupid I just knew they were
playing a different game I had to
understand why on a bad student I
learned by doing and so I set out to
build the best marketing machine is what
I would call it more than an agency and
and so you know we've grown very fast
the first two years I was still busy
with the wine business tonight a book
that went very viral that kind of
dragged me out there and but for the
last five years I've run the business
we've gone from 30 to 750 people from 3
to 100 million in revenue
all organic know ma so we built a real
big business and I think we've done it
because our interests have been aligned
with our clients because I'm not trying
to build an agency to sell to Martin
Sorrell I'm trying to buy build an
agency for myself to become my clients
which has allowed us to be very aligned
with our clients which is very different
than the marketplace of media agencies
and marketing agencies and we also do
every capability because I'm building it
for myself we do media buying and
creative and analytics and dev and so
that's that's why it happened well let's
talk about the early days then you said
you looked around and it's all these
brands doing quote-unquote stupid things
yes what are you you don't have to name
names it's how one get but give me some
examples about what were people doing
wrong yeah I mean look I mean to sit in
this room in October 2016 and have you
know it's funny let's take this go out
with one of your friends that has
nothing to do with marketing or business
and explain the following ok so here's
how it works a human a single human at
an agency a creative lead and another
human on the brand side and let me tell
you about the human on the brand side
this person went to business school to
sell stuff and run an operational P&L
these two people said the creative
single person humanly makes a subjective
call on a tag line and a video concept
narrows it down from the 7 or 8
ideations of his or her team to one or
two because you only have an hour to
presented they go to the human that is
there to run a pl and the two of them
make a subjective creative call of what
that business should stand for for the
entire year and then that company takes
sixty to eighty percent of its monies
and makes a single 30-second video to be
played in a commercial format in 2016
and this is to drive the sales of their
business there's no common sense human
on earth that thinks that's a good idea
we in the marketing world to play that
game
I think that's insanity that excites me
that's the opportunity no but really I
mean like like honestly like I mean I
you know I don't know who does what I
mean I'm not gonna be wrong let the
market play itself out but who watches a
commercial in 2016 like so here and I
want to quantify this I'm not a digital
list or a futurist I think the Superbowl
commercial is the number one buy in
marketing
if I buy brand tomorrow then and I have
a limited amount of money the first
thing I buy is the Super Bowl because
everybody in America is going through
pay attention to that whether they watch
it on YouTube or during the game and I
have 30 seconds to tell you what I'm
about
the problem with Super Bowl ads is there
a showcase for creative agencies to get
new clients and acquire more talent
they're not there to sell [ __ ] right so
I think that's the best buy in marketing
I think the worst buy in marketing in
the world is the second most expensive
commercial on television I don't know
what that is whether it's the Oscars or
the AFC Championship game or the Emmys I
don't know what it is but it's the worst
because we don't watch those commercials
it goes to commercial and we grab our
phone and we talk about that dress or
that play or what just happened our
attentions not there my living is very
simple in my bio where it says I build
businesses I don't know what paper my
team sends around these days but on the
website it says , I day trade attention
attention is the only asset it's the
only asset
and there's overpriced attention and
there's underpriced attention Direct
Mail is overpriced attention it works
spend $100,000 in direct mail you will
get things to happen but when you know
that there's a Facebook targeted world
out there that you could do it better
and cheaper that's a better idea and so
that's just what I spend my whole life
doing like what's overpriced what's
underpriced
what's practical I try to put myself out
of business every day if I started
vaynermedia today we would be an Alexa
voice message bot top-level domain
consultant video production vertical
phone shop so so so um I don't know what
are we talking about what you guys are
you talking about television you talked
about Facebook so from you know I
understand the people in the room here I
could say there are certain agencies
that specialize in television there are
certain agencies especially it's and
digital there's certain agencies that
yeah like you're saying specific voice
recognition chat BOTS you guys do
actually want to conquer it all yes and
when I say conquer at all
a my first level of responsibility is to
deliver for our clients cuz they're
paying us so Vayner in its current form
today what we want to do for a living is
we want to spend our clients money in a
way that sells them the most stuff or
whatever they're trying to achieve and
we are completely agnostic to where that
is
I built my career on Twitter it's where
I came out of for some of you that know
who I am I wasn't happy that Twitter was
losing attention in 2011 but when I was
making those videos five years ago like
I'm worried about this like I was
worried about it I was at the top of the
heap I was one of the 25 most follow
people in the world on Twitter like life
was good I wish Twitter stayed for a
thousand years it would have been easy I
wasn't happy to put in work on vine and
snapchat and Instagram it just it's not
my choice and what I'm fascinated by is
how many people are willing to draw
lines in the sand and hold on to things
because they're in their short term
financial vested interest it is a
massive business vulnerability and so
what do people need to get rid of like
if you had to give people a list of like
three things
maybe people should stop doing their
current agency's emotion emotions a good
thing to get rid of and I mean that I I
think like a lot of things that are
holding people back is the emotion of it
they hold certain things on a pedestal
we hold for example let me let me give
me a good example we think somehow in
our current society we've decided that
if you write another human being a
letter that you're somehow now the
greatest [ __ ] human being on earth
like we put things on pedestals for no
reason we are so scared of change that
we put writing a letter on a pedestal
because this somehow means you care so
much versus a text which at the end of
the day are exactly the same thing if
you write the same thing it's the
message is the same it's the medium of
delivery so I think the first thing that
people need to do is actually get rid of
emotion number two is have a real
conversation about measurement like
measurement is you know one of the great
things that happen to me is I started an
agency knowing nothing about the
business and I mean nothing I knew
nothing it was actually quite stupid but
you know but what I did know was my life
as an immigrant that had a family in
liquor store business our KPI was not
winning an award in France or getting a
headline in a magazine or some [ __ ]
modeling mix that was manipulated to
force the company to spend money on what
they believed in
like our KPI was selling Pinot Grigio
right and so having that DNA has helped
me the amount of times I've walked into
a meeting where the Millard Brown case
study the data logic study and the mmm
have said everything is phenomenal and
the business is down 17% is way too
often and somehow we accept that so I
think we have to have a far more serious
conversation around measurement because
we're measuring the wrong things this is
we are actually somehow eliminating
common sense from the equation there's a
lot I mean I just think it's
fundamentally fascinating I mean I don't
think agencies are built to all have
aligned interests with their clients
which is why you get into weird tactics
I think there's hitting cost and product
which is ludicrous I mean I don't know I
think the whole thing is fat I don't
think it's by the way Who am I I'm one
dude I just think that I just think that
it's a very interesting ecosystem like I
wouldn't do a meeting where the first
presentation was a by a PR company that
claimed that some mention in HuffPo 14
pages into their website
attributes 80 million impressions for
the month I mean like we're just playing
weird games I think we're a lack we're
just eliminating common sense and I
think that's a huge mistake yeah I think
metrics it's a great thing to talk about
in terms of that so way drugs of what
you're focused on when you present your
science I'm sure they still expect you
to present a report of the traditional
metric we do we we we do ton of
horseshit stuff because we they force us
to after this conversation we say to
them we want to measure sales you know
we want to measure nothing donations
like the thing like TV clients Nielsen
ratings because that's your currency
that you make money on like we want to
measure the thing the problem is 99% of
our clients do not put us in a position
to measure the thing which gets me into
like why doesn't anybody want to measure
to the thing right like like I think
nobody wants to be held accountable I
think one of the great things about
corporate America and agency landscape
that I didn't understand was I used to
be mad at everybody mad that you didn't
care enough to do the right thing then
what I realize is I can't be mad at you
the game is structured in a way that
people are playing within it because you
mortgages and a family and like you're
just you're making decisions not on what
you believe you're making decisions on
what is palpable and acceptable within
the ecosystem that's created I get it
I'm I'm more empathetic to it here's the
punchline though if you're doing
something to grow within an organization
or not rock the boat and have stability
it doesn't mean what you're doing is
right it just means it's right for you
within the context of games that you
chose in that human vulnerability is
enormous amounts of business opportunity
I plan to exploit that
so it in terms of that like you have
these conversations but people just
don't want to change right so how do you
make people change you don't do it you
you don't I could care less if anybody
changes as a matter of fact I'd prefer
that nobody changes because when I get
to the second part of this it'll give me
more time to do my thing so I just want
to be historically correct and I want to
inspire some people that just need a
little tip to go do the right thing and
I want to look back at these videos and
be like [ __ ] you were smart and and I
just want to just like just I mean
eventually see what's interesting for me
is there's a whole next generation of
people like and this is gonna create
business opportunities I'm right and
everybody knows it because you're right
you know it I'm not a genius I'm just in
a situation where I'm allowed to talk
about it in a way that's different than
a lot of people everybody knows you live
your life one way and then put you put
on your clothes that you wear to work
your Jersey and you act totally
different because you play within the
context of what's acceptable you don't
believe in the [ __ ] you're selling and I
don't mean all of you like a portion of
you I just I just genuinely believe that
you know why because at 3 o'clock in the
morning a can after a bottle of Rose a
you will tell me
so I don't know like it's interesting
and this happens everywhere like I yell
at kids to not take VC money because VCS
are giving you advice because they just
need one homerun and they're gonna drive
all the rest of you into the ground to
overextend your business because for
their business they just need one so
like I think you have to understand the
seed right like most of the agencies in
this room and in the market are part of
holding companies that are publicly
traded companies which means they have
to basically play a 90 day you know Wall
Street dynamics which that's what maps
their behavior
there's no HR talk you know like but for
me there's HR talk I spend all my time
on HR comma on the CEO because I'm
building something for the rest of my
life and I need these people so I have
to care about them so again it has
nothing to do with like anything other
than if you understand the North Star
and you can reverse-engineer it that is
where all that who answers are well then
may be a picture of how vaynermedia
looks I mean you call yourself the CEO
what a CEO mean at Vayner and who do you
surround yourself with that perhaps the
amateur as you know like it's different
than the current maybe structure of
other companies here no I think we have
a lot of similar structures I think the
only difference is that claude Silber my
cheap hard officers the number two
person in the company and that my CFO
scott has no say right so like we're not
financially driven right we're not
financially driven so that's probably
the only subtle difference we look like
everybody else you know I've tried
because I had blind you know at naive
eyes I did a lot of different things but
there's a lot of tried and true and the
way you should be structured I think I
think the thing that the one thing that
my leads know is I don't want so
nobody's incentivized to grow business
so one thing that's weird about us is a
lot of people come from all these great
shops and they think they need to throw
the PNL because they'll get a bonus and
that's good for them so I've eliminated
that because I want our team to play
well in the sandbox with other partners
because that's the right thing for the
client and the only way you can really
do that is if you create the
infrastructure for that because if you
incentivize them around dollar
are gonna fight for dollars right so the
only thing they have to do is be
historically correct like to mean people
that move brands this and that like a
lot more people give us business today
by the things they thought we were
stupid about three years ago and now
they believe in right people don't
forget so I don't need to win the scope
I need to make sure that everybody
understands where we stand on how it
plays out and what's in the best
interest to sell the product and so
those are the things that are different
but otherwise I don't know we have a
creative department we have account we
have strategy insights analytics it's
the same horseshit well if you had to
you know add a new division or expand in
a certain way what what would you do
next
unlimited resources what are you doing
that's only thinking we're I think we do
that I mean I'm losing all sorts of
money investing in you know message body
infrastructure we have Boehner smart the
smart efficacious stuff like I'm again
building it for myself thus I'm losing
on my P&L every day with departments
that don't return because the clients
don't want it yet to me I'm always
building for something that's 1224
months ahead of time I don't think you
should build anything for five years out
I think that lacks practicality I think
if you see the world in a 12 or 18 month
window and you can go there that feels
real and that's what I've kind of tried
to rinse and repeat so we do a lot of
that you know we invested in vertical
video people two to three years ago
because we saw that playing out and
that's worked out for us because the
market has moved more in that direction
we you know we invested in 70 you know
what I would call new digital paid media
people who probably believe more in feed
dynamics of social networks than
programmatic banner buying or you know
things of that nature
and that's working out for us so I think
you know I'm it's not even unlimited
budgets what I think I'm doing now which
is if I believe anything is meaningful
to sell something or communicate
something we will invest in it
immediately we have we've analysts and
strategists who spend time on analyzing
musically a year ago you know and so
that's just kind of how we go
awesome well increasing you guys have
offices in multiple places do you want
to grow your physical presence anytime
soon
yes we've been office in New York LA San
Francisco Chattanooga Tennessee and
London so I'll speak about Chattanooga
Tennessee in London Chattanooga is one
of probably five to seven more offices
that I will build in cities that are not
New York LA San Francisco and Boston
there's another part of America I don't
know if you've heard and though there's
a lot of it and so I want to have
offices there because they buy by a
brand that mainly sells in Middle
America at Dollar General having a
footprint to these markets for a decade
is gonna be smart
same thing with London and Asia and
other places will expand I'm only I'm
very single-minded well I'm gonna buy
brands that are under priced because big
holding companies are not supporting
great brands because they don't have the
money for it they're only supporting top
five brands they're gonna sell it to me
for a nickel on the dollar I'm gonna buy
it I'm gonna refurbish it in a 2022
world for whatever that is and I'm gonna
run it through my machine with the
people that have been with me for 15
years because we give a [ __ ] about them
and then we're gonna build the [ __ ] out
of it flip it buy the New York Jets win
do you see yourself then it's keeping
vaynermedia like as it is you know when
you buy the Jets as vaynermedia is still
gonna be around that's something I
didn't say which I hate talking about I
thought I thought I would build like a
hundred person shop it'd be great we'd
buy a brand you know I take 40 people
over to it I would help the other 60 get
jobs or put them in my other investments
like really take care of the crew and
move on my merry way what ended up
happening is look we've gone from 30 to
750 people in four years five years like
there's gonna be a lot more people than
I anticipated when the brand comes so
now I've started you know I've written a
bunch of books I've started writing one
called the by accident billion dollar
company and it's really The Chronicles
of building Vayner and why I did it and
what happened and why did I why was I
able to build a big big big business
really fast because our interests are
aligned with our client like it's like
it's just you know it's always things
it's always at the tippy top right like
everything that's broke in a Boehner
media my fault everything is about the
top so now I realize oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
have a holding company of brands but in
parallel I'm also gonna have vaynermedia
I'm gonna take the top talent each year
and graduate them into the brands that I
own but to interestings are gonna happen
one I think I'm gonna be able to get the
best talent in the world into Boehner
because if the word on the street is if
you go work at Vayner and you crush it
that you can then go and work on Hershey
Kisses or what or heads and get a piece
of the action and make lots and lots of
money that's gonna bring unbelievable
talent and to when I go pitch for new
business at vaynermedia instead of
saying like here's our sizzle reel or
our capes I'm gonna be like hey four and
a half years ago we bought Snickers it
was doing 237 million in revenue now
it's doing eight point seven billion
because of what we did
that's our pitch [ __ ]
so yeah I be convincing someone to work
at mater I don't think she'd be too hard
I don't think so I think like look I
mean like everybody here knows that that
works and it like and they and they
respect it and I respect it I'm not mad
at a holding company they're not you
know what are they like it's not
non-profit world
it's just you have to be smart about why
things do what they do and I think that
I'm excited to create a new model in
this ecosystem because one thing I have
done is fallen in love with the DNA of
the people within it these are
storytellers these are sales people like
these are ma this is cool this is what I
am I didn't realize it like this is what
I am - a little bit of a different
version of it but pretty much what I am
and so I think the machines that have
been put in place aren't great for the
people and I think that it's I'm not
gonna be able to employ everybody what
I'm gonna do is be ridiculously
successful and inspire Sally to go and
build it - and create all new
alternatives great well we have about
five minutes left so I wanted to open up
the audience Q&N yes don't you ensuing
firing get any questions anyone anyone
here questions awesome
he said you don't incentivize people for
new business how do you go about new
business do you find that people are
coming to you because they know you do
you get involved in pitches how do you
go about growing both of those things
and then the other thing that I didn't
know cuz I wasn't from the industry is
when you do really good work and people
believe in you and they go move to other
companies you get them right so a lot of
it comes from my personal brand equity
like I'm not building the garyvee [ __ ]
for just my ego you know and so we get
that but at this point we're at such
massive scale you know whether it's the
GE work or the Pepsi work or or the
Toyota work or the you know we're out
we're doing a lot of business and a lot
of people are moving and we're just
winning word of mouth again
I'm telling you as cool as I am and I go
to the sales meeting I'm a great
salesman it's the only thing that
matters is the steak not the sizzle the
sizzle is the gateway drug to the steak
and and that's why we're growing
what percentage of what my friend AB
incentive compensation like like if we
grow this business they'll kick us back
dollars zero and and by the way I'd love
to do all of it that way the problem is
these CFOs and procurement and corporate
America think I'm an idiot
yeah like the incentive plans are
ludicrous and by the way I would take it
but nobody's we're not big enough yet or
like real enough yet for corporate
America for them to really let me
control everything not gonna be at the
mercy of like Digitas as media plan you
know I have to run and that's not a dig
at Digitas first thing you know that's
it's just them I need to be if I'm gonna
be if like I'm like on the on the line I
need to control everything then it's
real right so zero so far though it's
kind of weirdly what I thought I was
gonna do you know stinks but I think I'm
gonna play the ultimate version of that
when I write a check for eighty eight
million dollars right
- bye pop rockets you know like like
it's you know it's gonna it's gonna
that's the ultimate putting your money
where your mouth is and that's what I
came from that's what I'm actually way
more comfortable with all this
politicking worship
hi I'm behind the pillar I'll step
forward
since you said you want to serve the
people in this room they just heard
about a half an hour ago that they're
the most depressed people in the agency
I'm sorry they just heard they're the
most depressed group of people who these
people mm-hmm in the agency world
because they're strategists Oh what do
you say to them I mean what's you know
what do you say to help you know I
probably can't you know one thing I've
really enjoyed about me getting more
comfortable in my own skin is I like
saying I don't know more than I used to
I'm not sure to had it fully answer that
I'll tell you I'm a weird guy to ask
that this I don't know how this is gonna
come off but I was really against having
a strategy department because I was like
why would I hire people to just be a
count like and just be you know
management I need people to think what
you guys know what I've learned is not
everybody can do both I've come to learn
that you know I don't I don't know why
they're the most depressed from what
I've learned and this is this is great I
think you guys might enjoy this because
it's really coming from left field and I
don't have a lot of good data on this
other than my own experiences I think
you guys are being held on a pedestal in
most places right like like I when I
look at a lot of places that I like I'm
like I'm so surprised that like nobody
talks until the strategist talks or
things of that nature I also think maybe
I saw the lovely lady with the
camouflage shake her hand I was like I
was like okay that maybe she means like
like to me it's crazy that the creep
like in a creative shop the creative is
the most powerful in a world where this
is all subjective until it hits the
market you know I
so I don't know the context of why the
market would think strategists are the
most oppressed is it because strategists
are similar to CMOS which is they have
say but not the ultimate say and people
[ __ ] up their thoughts in execution I'm
not sure but but here here you know
maybe so but here's what I'm gonna say
but here's what I must say but then
creatives are going to talk about how
the media plan [ __ ] them up and listen
it like everybody's everybody's [ __ ]
crying like like every discipline is
crying if this was a [ __ ] creative
they would say that's like everybody
crying I think people need to stop
crying that we need to think I think
people I think people need to start
understanding how much of this is
subjective by the way the agency big
brand world
everything happens upfront all the
fighting and the jockeying and the work
and the debating all this [ __ ] happens
up front guys we live in 2017 this all
needs to happen after it hits the market
I mean this whole thing is so [ __ ] up
it's built for television it's not 1986
sorry
go read what happened in the late 50s
and early 60s mid 50s early 60s on the
transition of radio to television that's
what we're living through and then you
will start making very different
decisions in your career and probably in
your strategy meetings are you pre have
time for one more yeah let's do it
hi Gary how are you good thank you okay
so I'm an immigrant too and I totally
support your ambitions and
I believe you'll buy the joint I love
you and I'll be the one cheering you on
thank you but I'm just curious how you
see America has changed for you to
execute those ambitions from when you
were a child till now that's a great
question I think not a whole lot I mean
that I think what immigrants especially
Soviet immigrants that truly come from
communism understand is there's certain
things that are worse there's certain
things that are better you know it's
evolved but like I always deal in
alternatives like here's what I know in
the last eight years 12 years actually
at last 12 years I've had friends on
both sides of the aisle who told me if
this person wins they're moving to
Canada right if Bush gets reelected I'm
moving to Canada if Obama gets reelected
I'm moving to Canada so far nobody's
[ __ ] move to Canada
so you know you know I don't like for me
to ever think for a purebred
entrepreneur to ever think the President
of the United States has any impact on
her or his ability to execute in this
game they're a [ __ ] loser so I don't
I don't think it's changed at all I
think there's a lot of different
dynamics and I think if you really
really really want to look at Ana
macro-level you know what I'm most
thankful for that it's even for all the
horseshit we have around gender and
minority or things of that nature
my daughter is in a better position to
execute then she would have been if she
was my age
it gets better I don't give a [ __ ] what
the world tries to tell you of how bad
it is because that's what drives Nielsen
ratings on mainstream media it's [ __ ]
good it's good like the problem is we
are sold the one percent that's bad
every single day 24/7 365 so I think
it's great super opportunity I think
that's the perfect note to end on and
the opportunity point